we're going to begin with breaking news
from south korea on president biden just
moments ago he made remarks as he kicks
off a strategically crucial trip to
visit allies in asia south korea has a
brand new leader already being tested by
renewed renewed threats from the north
and of course china will be high on the
agenda as well nancy cordes is traveling
with the president in seoul nancy good
morning
good morning to you tony the president
has made this trip halfway around the
world to bolster u.s alliances at a
pivotal time and while he's here in asia
he's going to sit down with the leaders
of south korea japan australia and india
as they contend with new provocations
from china and north korea
president biden landed in seoul and
headed straight to a samsung
semiconductor plant with south korea's
new president samsung is building a
similar factory in texas president biden
president yun
this visit comes as president biden
seeks to establish a new economic
framework in asia one that can challenge
china's dominance and doesn't rely on
supply from autocratic countries like
russia
as president biden stops in south korea
the white house is girding for a
possible provocation from the north
with u.s intelligence indicating the
north koreans might try to test a
long-range missile or even a nuclear
missile while mr biden is here we are
coordinating closely with our allies in
both korea and japan on this ryu yonwu
is a former north korean diplomat who
defected in 2019
he says the timing of north korea's
saber rattling is no accident
this is a chance he says to send a
strong message to south korea and the
u.s to change their policies for example
lifting sanctions on north korea or a
ban on joint military exercises between
south korea and the u.s
u.s officials say neither of those
things will happen as long as north
korea continues to pursue its nuclear
program amid this heightened security
situation the president is no longer
considering making a stop at the dmz the
demilitarized zone between south and
north korea gail all right nancy cordes
reporting from south korea we thank you